many people have clamored for aggressive
action on student loans for years
and while joe biden ran on easing the
burdens of loan borrowers
his ability to act on those proposals
won't be an easy one
so how could a biden administration work
towards easing borrowers burdens or
outright cancelling student loans
so typically student loans which if they
are cancelled would happen through
congress congress under the u.s
constitution
is the branch of government that is
responsible for federal spending so most
likely if there is student loan
cancellation there is no guarantee
it would come through congress the top
question about forgiving student loans
is which party will control
congress in the next legislative term
currently
democrats control the house but right
now there are runoff elections in
georgia for the us senate
if republicans can retain control of
congress it is
less likely there will be student loan
forgiveness at least through a
congressional legislative bill
another way it could pass would be
through stimulus legislation
after all the march cares act provided
some debt relief for borrowers
and while experts don't expect a bill
will pass by the end of the year
stimulus could come in 2021 under the
new administration
the third way would be the most
controversial through executive action
now the issue is this really doesn't
have a precedent typically as i said
congress has the power of the purse
so there may be legal challenges in the
court system
that could for example have a temporary
injunction preventing student loan
forgiveness
if president biden decided to use
executive action importantly he has not
said whether he would consider executive
action
but there are members of congress and
scholars and legal analysts who have
proposed
uh that he'd do that including senator
elizabeth warren massachusetts
but there are other paths towards easing
borrower student loan burdens without
full cancellation they'll still require
cooperation from congress
but could be less controversial one of
those is forgiveness for people making
less than 125 thousand dollars for
public college graduates
and for future borrowers you might have
to take on less loans
one of his proposals is for two-year and
four-year public colleges
to be tuition free it would just be for
college not for graduate school
biden also wants to change how much
borrowers have to pay
under their income based repayment plan
so currently they're about 10 to 20
of your discretionary income and that
may lower to as low as five percent of
your discretionary
income if that plan becomes a reality
and finally
a biden administration could make public
service loan forgiveness
more attractive to borrowers this is a
program to forgive your federal student
loans for people who work
for a qualified employer in public
service or a non-profit
so you have to pay 120 monthly payments
which is about 10 years
under biden's plan you could receive
student loan forgiveness sooner in about
five years
[Music]
you